la question c'est de quoi est-ce qu'on
parle quand on parle de démocratie
et s'il dit si je parle d'expérience
démocratique ou de démocratique comme
expérience
c'est parce que la démocratie ne se
réduit pas à un système juridique au
politique
qu'elle n'est pas seulement un mode de
gouvernement ou un régime au sens étroit
du terme c'est à dire un certain mode de
répartition d'organisation d'exercices
du pouvoir bien sûr un certain nombre
d'éléments de structure
institutionnels sont fondamentaux
l'existence d'un état de droit la
séparation ou plutôt l'équilibre des
pouvoirs plus conformes l'idée et à
l'inspiration dans Montesquieu la
présence des contres pouvoirs tout ceci
est absolument essentiel mais la
démocratie c'est aussi comme le disait
Tocqueville dans la démocratie en
Amérique une forme de société
et une forme de société cela implique
des dispositions subjectives propres à
l'homo-démocraticus c'est à dire une
manière d'être et de vivre ou de ne pas
vivre ensemble un style d'existence des
mœurs des assises mentales et affectives
c'est en ce sens que la démocratie est
une expérience qui englobe à la fois les
pratiques de pouvoir et des positions
subjectives en particulier la démocratie
c'est ce régime paradoxal où la
contradiction publique des actions du
pouvoir est considérée comme légitime
on doit être attentif aux institutions
mais à la condition de considérer que la
démocratie c'est d'abord un mode
d'existence qui ne se réduit pas à la
sanction électorale et à des formes
strictement
procédurales la démocratie
représentative ne signifie pas que les
citoyens doivent rester silencieux après
avoir voté et en attendant la prochaine
élection à côté des élections ils
gardent la possibilité de s'exprimer de
contester de délibérer et surtout d'être
entendu